welcome to supermarket swings
[Music]
hey it's me hannah and today we're doing
something a little different because i
could not be more excited that leslie
jones is taking over sunday nights with
the all-new supermarket sweep on abc
prime time supermarket sweep was my
favorite game show when i was a kid and
i want to get my kids just as pumped for
the return as i am today we're doing our
own version of a little game show pantry
sweep to celebrate supermarket suite
premieres sunday october 18th at 8 7
central on abc here are the rules i have
a recipe for a homemade rainbow
sprinkles cake using only ingredients i
already have in my pantry but it's up to
my two boys jackson and wyatt to figure
out what those ingredients are by
answering a few clues first then they'll
have to race against the clock to sweep
through the pantry and find all the
ingredients for this recipe but here's
the thing i can only use the ingredients
that they bring me even if they bring me
the wrong stuff so this should be
interesting to say the least but let's
get started i'm ready to go
are you guys ready to answer some
questions i'm yellow but i'm not a
rubber duck i come in a stick shape but
i don't grow on trees i can be spread on
toast but i'm not jammed butter butter
butter butter
you guys butter awesome next clue
humpty dumpty was one of these before he
fell off the wall
hey
yeah
yeah that's good y'all are killing this
game i love it all right this is a
two-part clue are you ready yeah yes the
first word is what you see after it
rains
yes
excellent okay
part two my name and what i do are the
same
word but i taste the best when i'm on
top of ice cream
sprinkles you got it
now that you guys got all the clues are
you ready to find your ingredients yes
all right
get set
go
wow
butter you got it
all right don't give up and you got me
baking powder
oh no baby what you doing
what are you doing
what are these wyatts
sprinkles sprinkles
sprinkles okay
that is how you play the game
i think i have all that i need to make a
delicious dessert
so the boys gave me rainbow colored
cereal instead of sprinkles and
marshmallows so that gave me the idea to
make a marshmallow cereal treat and
that'll incorporate into my bigger
dessert and i think it'll taste really
good now i'd intended to make a rainbow
sprinkle cake for this recipe but i have
a few wild card ingredients here that's
the cereal the marshmallows and the
brown sugar brown sugar works way better
in cookies so i'm going to take these
ingredients and pivot completely i'm
going to create a stuffed skillet cookie
the first thing i'm going to use is this
rainbow cereal the marshmallows and some
butter i'm going to make some
marshmallow cereal treats these are
really simple they come together so
quickly you basically melt it all in a
pot stir in your cereal press it into a
pan and cool that so once it's cool i'm
going to cut these into small squares
and i will use these in my cookie moving
on to the cookie dough i'm going to
start by combining my dry ingredients
we've got flour baking powder baking
soda and salt
so the wet ingredients are brown sugar
butter
vanilla extract and one large egg and
two large egg yolks so here's a tip for
separating your eggs so you can get nice
clean yolks do it when the eggs are at
room temperature they'll separate really
easily so now it's time to combine the
wet and the dry ingredients and i'm
going to stir those up until it's just
mixed because i'm adding more cereal to
this and i'm going to mix it again
you don't want to over mix your dough
you want it to be just combined so you
get a nice delicious fluffy cookie
time to press this down into the cast
iron i'm using about a third of the
dough mixture then i'm going to take my
little squares of cereal treats and
press those into the dough that's going
to be the stuffing for this skillet
cookie and then use the rest of the
dough to top them now this is key when
the cookie is still hot gently press the
remaining treat squares into the top of
the cookie i'm gonna scatter some
marshmallows from my cereal over the top
and let this cool in the pan for about
20 minutes it smells amazing i can't
wait to see what the boys think
um
yes
[Applause]
good i like it better than cake
well that was the most fun i've had in
the kitchen in such a long time and that
cookie turned out delicious thank you so
much for challenging me didn't it turn
out good
i didn't like it i loved it
make sure you try this pantry challenge
at home and don't forget when you're at
the checkout and you hear the beat
think of all the fun you'll have on
supermarket suite
on supermarket suite the more you spend
the closer you get to that hundred
thousand dollar jackpot
y'all killing this game
you